là aussi ça c'était pas là il ya deux
semaines fait que quelqu'un qui s'est
relogé qui est en train de remonter
quelque chose lors faire le tour des
chantiers de construction à montréal
c'est presque devenu le quotidien de
sylvia rivest tour a été barricadée
justement pour sécuriser les ont
sécurisé les zones de travaux veut aussi
dire chasser les itinérants parfois bien
installé un phénomène qui n'est pas
nouveau mais avec la multitude de
chantiers de construction à montréal
difficile de les déplacer elle a
maintenant un manque d espace donc les
gens vont aller 6 all in en des endroits
où est ce que ça pourrait devenir
éventuellement dangereux les
constructions tout partout en ville et
fait des ménages et au musée ni comme ça
david vit dans la rue depuis presque
cinq ans david c'est le nom qu'on lui a
données pour préserver son anonymat
en 2014 il s'est fait évincer de son
logement il n'a pas pu retrouver un
endroit abordable depuis incroya quand
j'ai regardé le journal
deux places ok un place un deux et demi
pour faire sens aussi parce qu'il n'ya
pas que les nombreux chantiers qui
rendent l'itinérance plus visible à
montréal et prix élevé des loyers aussi
contribuer à changer le visage de la
pauvreté
il ya des gens qui vont perdre leurs
logements qui vont sortir en situation
de pauvreté à rougemont à pointe aux
trembles dans l'ouest de l'île et qui
vont rester parc ont serré gens l'ont
pas autant de services en itinérance
qu'on en au centre-ville en trois ans
montréal a connu une augmentation de 12%
des personnes en situation d'itinérance
une hausse inquiétante qui laisse
craindre le pire pour les intervenants
on n'est pas à l'abri des situations qui
comme à vancouver
comme à san francisco et d'autres villes
qui vit
une croissance flagrant dans le nombre
de personnes à la rue parce que personne
n'est complètement à l'abri n'existe
aucun bouclier magique qu'on peut pas se
protéger contre un épisode de santé
mentale une dépression nerveuse une
mauvaise séparation une faillite
issigeac audrey charbonneau raid au
canada montréal